this is on Tucker's show talking about
the possible arrest and the lack of
response from the Biden white house
because if you separate
all of this from what you think Trump
did or didn't do or porn stars and
payoffs and everything else we enter
Banana Republic type stuff when you
start or arresting political opponents
for nonsensical things right and you
make everyone think man the whole system
is corrupt and once everyone thinks the
whole system is corrupt that's a system
that is ripe to fail because it only
works as long as we believe that it can
work that's what Tucker was addressing
right here
these about when and where Donald Trump
will be arrested fingerprinted and
photographed against a cinder block wall
for his mug shot
how much of this is true once again we
cannot say here's what we know a Soros
funded prosecutor in New York a man who
ran on the promise to indict Trump seems
to be working hard to indict Trump
indebting him for a crime that no one
even pretends is a crime including the
federal agency that has already
investigated and declared it on a crime
so in Manhattan tomorrow what will
certainly be an overwhelmingly liberal
grand jury will meet and unless
something unexpected happens Democrats
will have taken the unprecedented step
of using a corrupt justice system to
take out the front runner in the
Republican Presidential field in a
presidential race and if that happens
America will never be the same you've
got to hope that for the sake of the
country the Biden White House
which will be running against Trump will
put the country above partisanship and
stop this the mayor Garland at doj will
issue a very public statement saying
that this is wrong which it is and
therefore preserve for our grandchildren
our justice system the overriding point
of if you do if you guys go ahead and do
this
on some nonsensical misdemeanor
technicality from years ago that
everyone is way past it is so obvious
that you're doing it just for political
purposes that the fire that you are
going to ignite is going to be it's
going it potentially could burn
everything down and it could also be the
fuel that sends Trump back into the
White House right if you think about it
the energy now although I'm telling you
that the Trump energy is actually the
Santa's energy people are talking about
Trump again right they are it's just a
simple fact whether you like Trump or
not had they not done this people
wouldn't be talking about him so you
guys you're laying your own trap here uh
anyway Tucker also related to this uh
related this to the D.A himself who is
doing virtually nothing on crime in New
York City which is skyrocketing and
actually not doing nothing he's
reversing some very obvious policies on
how you deal with criminals
so here you have a D.A who treats
violent felonies like they're
misdemeanors even when it gets people
killed who's unleashing criminals on the
population but then spending all of his
time trying to destroy his political
opponents in this case elevating a
misdemeanor charge to the a felony for
the purpose of taking down Trump right
so if anyone should be looked into here
it's the D.A it's brag at this point
like are you doing things because you
are following the letter of the law
which is what your job is as a D.A
you're supposed to decide what cases get
pushed what people get off what all the
actual technical legal justifications
are for someone being arrested what
we're going to spend time investigating
etc etc are you doing that or are you
doing things for a a much broader
political purpose I think that's fairly
obvious and then Tucker didn't hold back
on what would what the outcome would be
if they go ahead and do this thing
taking out your opponent using the
justice system
if the Democratic party is allowed to do
this allowed to crush the presidential
front-runner the main threat to their
power with a bogus criminal case where
does that leave us we're done
because that precedent will live forever
yeah he's totally right
[Music]